sup guys Jerry here coming at you with
just a quick a movie review I want to
get back into this it's been a long time
I apologized that life is busy man
throws curveballs your way um so this is
just a simple one I figured a simple one
might be a nice way to get back into
things everybody talking about Star Wars
but I also saw another movie this
weekend i saw sisters which is the new
film from Tina Fey and Amy Poehler yeah
let's get into this real quick off the
top I think this is a funny movie I left
a lot like pound for pound if you're
just judging by laughs I laughed a lot
at this movie um it's about two sisters
one of whom is very sheltered very safe
she's a decent job you know her life is
figured out to a degree she's just
recently divorced you know she's she's
figured out but there's not a lot of
spice or flavor in her life and then you
have Tina Fey who is the wild sister who
does not have her [ __ ] together who is
like a single parent and this movies
it's just kind of like a coming-of-age
story for two adults who who should have
grown up by now we have the sort of man
child trope this is kind of like woman
children growing up and then coming of
age and stuff like that and how does
that happen well they go back home their
parents are selling their childhood
house they're freaking out about this
and they decide to go back and relive
the glory days and throw a big-ass party
because they were you know the queens of
party back in high school in their
hometown and
chaos ensues from there and this this
movie it's pretty simple man like this
movie is incredibly loose it's a riff
based you know improv based comedy we
get a lot of these it's a it's a very
popular American genre of comedy and
your enjoyment of this film will kind of
hinge upon just whether or not you find
these people and these jokes funny and I
did like I laughed a lot of this stuff
there are a lot of characters to show up
I mean Tina Fey and Amy Poehler I think
they have a great chemistry together
they are very funny together there are a
lot of people who show up in this james
brolin and Dianne Wiest of their parents
Bobby Moynihan is in this my Rudolph
Kate McKinnon is in it for a second John
Cena pops up but he's really funny like
he's very funny Bobby Moynihan's in this
and I mean he's he's funny like is the
thing is like these are a lot of these
characters the kinds of characters that
could very well get annoying and
incessant and I'm sure some people
probably do find them annoying and
incessant but for me you know Bobby
Moynihan tickles me pink and he tickled
me pink in this this is one of those
comedies that's sort of about
dysfunctional people learning how to
become more functional and it has a few
slightly more poignant plot twists
thrown in you know when the gauntlet is
thrown down and and the world calls on
these characters to really make a change
I mean the characters get called on
their [ __ ] in a reasonably effective
way but not before a huge amount of
hijinks happens this becomes the kind of
movie after a while that you sort of
cringe through or at least I do where
they're throwing this party things are
getting more and more out of hand and
you know there's just so much
destruction and some of it is pretty
over the top it is a slapstick
disastrous comedy and as a movie you
know not even in terms of like story
structure but like as a movie the flow
of the story is pretty loose this is the
kind of film that can easily dip into
tedium ER into being painful to watch
it's the kind of thing I could easily
see somebody not liking I can easily see
somebody sitting down to this and going
these people or [ __ ] and this is a
shitty situation and I'm not having fun
and a lot of the deciding factor that is
just how you feel about these particular
people and these particular jokes like
me as a viewer I don't love these kinds
of comedies but I really enjoyed the
chemistry I really enjoyed the people
that got to fill the supporting cast and
what they brought to this like this is a
script that I think is brought to life
by the people involved with it because
I've seen movies of this sort that I
don't like I'd almost go so far to say
it's kind of as much of a mess as the
party in the film itself is it just so
happens that I laughed it a lot of the
jokes and you may feel differently it's
incredibly loose it's probably a little
too long but I didn't mind because the
character stuff is funny there's enough
pathos in there to make it you know
slightly more rewarding than your
average crazy party movie you could take
these same characters and probably make
a better film out of them a more deep
and poignant film but there is some nice
coming-of-age stuff and wacky comedy
very funny vignettes and side characters
and stuff like that so yeah I enjoyed
sisters all right you know it's not my
favorite comedy of the year but if you
think you liked this movie you'll
probably like it it's nice to have a
very funny female driven comedy that
probably won't be passed off as being
just for girls you know cuz that's kind
of [ __ ] you know it's this is a
comedy and
I think if you like this kind of comedy
at all you'll probably like this book so
uh so yeah sisters Tina Fey and Amy
Poehler did you like it let's talk
what's your favorite Tina Fey or Amy
Poehler piece you know what do you like
most from them and until next time my
name is Jerry sisters is the film cheers
you
you